bill cosby once considered a role model  and called america's dad is now facing  up to 30 years in prison this morning a  jury convicted the 80 year old comedian  three counts of aggravated indecent  assault yesterday in that trial Andrea  constant testified that Cosby drugged  and molested her in his pennsylvania  home 14 years ago more than 60 women say  Cosby sexually assaulted them one of  them Chelan lascia testified against the  comedian for 30 years 32 years I've  dreamt about this thing I've had  nightmares but what he had done to me  and I knew one day out it happened I  feel free I feel free because I've  always told the truth  a lot of the victims feel that way Cosby  says his relationship with constand was  consensual his lawyers say they will  appeal the verdict